the world next door  where i come from it seems like  everybody has an immigrant story the  harbor of buenos aires beckon newcomers  from all over the world my ancestors  were italian where spanish were indian  and the only thing i had to do is to go  out of the house to experience a  different language a different culture i  remember sneaking out in spring to  celebrate passover with my jewish  friends we also had lebanese neighbors  and their religious festivities also  became part of our celebrations in the  family i think that all argentines carry  a piece of the world with them and  that's why it's relatively easy for me  to walk in other people's shoes my work  is not only about political and social  issues i want to find out what's below  the surface the issues and the stories  that have shaped the people i want to  show that even though we are all  different there is a general human  condition that connects us all  my name is fia castro and i work at dw  [Music]  you